do you even get cell service like if
you're in the sky
uh
i do
my sleigh and reindeer are all fully
equipped with all the latest technology
really you guys got like the technology
package oh absolutely we were
retrofitted about uh four years ago wow
that's wild um has there been like um
like this year has it been a lot scarier
for kids to like request gifts has there
been like a lot less interaction like
what's it been like for you like
interacting with the kids well for me
where i'm at four days a week it's same
business as usual however there are some
parents that
want their children to still socially
distanced so we put them on the bench
seat that i normally would sit on and
then behind it we have a little
fireplace and a christmas tree and i
hide behind the christmas tree and then
i peek out and i do a sh or a
surprise face look type of thing
i love that so that works out fine and
some of them they'll do the first
picture while they're sitting on my lap
with their mask on and then they'll take
the mask off after that that way they
want to
uh
i guess chronologically capture the 2020
moment yeah
are some kids more special than others
santa do you think
well they're special needs children yeah
and they come and see me all the time
too and they're the they're very around
pardon me you mean like year-round
year-round see because i am santa
and i
am naturally fat and i have white hair
and a white beard
uh children come up to me all the time
during the year well if i'm out grocery
shopping or we're out at a restaurant or
someplace like sometimes even when i'm
at a gas station yeah filling up the
vehicles uh oh yeah if i've been
sniffing gas i'll accuse somebody of
being santa that's for sure so i always
uh have little coins or trinkets or
things of that sort i'll spend a moment
or two talking with them and then i'll
give them something
um how did the spirit of christmas kind
of start like in your heart and stuff
like that yeah i've always loved
children okay
and that's the main reason that i do
this is to
uh so the children who will have the
best experience with santa's possible
each year one of the early macy's
new york city santas his name was
charles w howard and he's famous for
having quoted the
or
creating the quote
he airs who thinks santa enters through
the chimney
santa enters through the heart um and
that's very very true
yeah i guess there's a there's an
element of just keeping that alive in
children huh keeping that that that
ability for anything to be possible sure
everything's possible yeah yeah do you
feel like a responsibility whenever you
see the kids like um
do you feel some like uh is it hard to
gear up and just show up every day and
be santa
the season does get long
and mrs claus is always ready for at the
end because she does a lot to help me
get ready every day oh does she really
oh yeah
she curls my hair and my beard with
little mini hot rollers ooh damn and uh
from the time i get into the shower
until the time i walk out the front door
it's about a two-hour process
45 minutes of which i'm sitting there
with these curlers everywhere
and where'd you meet your mrs claus at
i met mrs claus in virginia beach oh yes
and it's
been 33 years since then we've been
married
and will um will mrs claus kind of uh
does she have like a favorite meal that
she prepares for you kind of
yes cookies all the time cookies really
so that's not just a myth right no
that's not a myth i love
every kind of cookie there is so when a
children ask me what's my favorite
cookie i say i love all the cookies i've
never met a cookie i didn't like
now was there um was there ever a time
where there was i heard like rumors and
stuff that there was a time where some
of the reindeer wasn't
you know there was like some of them was
kind of struggling doing you know not
drugs but like just struggling with
stuff that they were going through was
there ever a time where they were going
to replace some of the reindeer
well we always have reindeer in training
okay
for example this year i've got two
reindeer
that are hoping to make santa's reindeer
team next year and their names are holly
and jolly oh really oh yeah
okay and uh they're working hard a
couple max preps out there i like that
so they're kind of on the uh junior
varsity right there on the junior
varsity that's right
and so what kind of training and stuff
do they have to do for reindeer because
i imagine like at some point part of the
element is you grant them the ability to
fly well that's through waffle dust
you don't know what wiffle dust is
well let me tell you i think it's
probably the reason i've lived as long
as i live
a lot of people think that i go to
deliver all the toys in 24 hours they
think that i go around the world this
way
east to west east to west east to west
but i don't i go north to south north to
south and every time i get back to the
north
i land at the north pole
people don't realize it there's so many
good children in the world now and it
takes so many toys to take care of them
i can't have a sleigh large enough to
haul all those so you got to make all
those trips so we make all those trips
there's in in the world there's 24 time
zones and we do one time zone every hour
that's how we can do the whole world in
24 hours and when we land at the north
pole here's what happens three things
they always come out and put all kinds
of more toys in the sleigh
mrs claus meets me at the sleigh
uh and gives me some coffee or a hot
chocolate or cider or something like
that she'll prep you up she'll kind of
keep your morale up and
this special elf that we have
who has the formula to make waffle dust
she comes out
and one of the things that she does
before we take take off again is she
hovers and she sprinkles waffle dust all
over the reindeer oh yeah and all over
the sleigh and then right there beside
me on the sleigh is a giant bag of
waffle ducks damn okay because i'll tell
you what
i travel to some of the places in the
world and the weather's just terrible i
mean it's really really bad yeah and you
don't want santa and the sleigh sliding
off these icy roofs so what we do is we
circle the house sprinkle a little
waffle dust on it and that way the
reindeer have sure footing whenever they
land
i like that yeah it's great here's a
question that came in for you right here
santa here's a question from one of our
listeners what's up theo what's up mall
santa just taking a dump right now
mall santa
sir
what is the rowdiest uh
kid you ever had on what did they ask
for what did they do
and uh in general how do you deal with
the situation like that
um
especially with parents there uh
what are you doing so gang gang take
dumps jesus
well the rowdy children uh
i talk with them a little bit about not
being as rough and tumble as they are
that that's just a big show that they're
trying to put on
okay and as far as the children that ask
for everything because i have some
children they bring the whole
toys r us book or whatever where are
they
getting their toys out of and they're
being greedy oh yeah they're being
greedy i knew and so what i tell them i
said now if the last little boy or girl
that had come to see me
who asked for everything
if i said okay i'll bring you everything
then you wouldn't get anything because
it'll all be gone so we all have to
share in this world
and what do kids want over the years
what have you noticed that children
really want them is there a couple of
common gifts that really stand out
well over the breadth of time i know
each year there's kind of a novel gift
believe it or not
every year i get a bunch of requests for
pogo sticks are you serious oh yeah
i do
wow and sometimes i get i don't get so
much anymore hula hoops yeah but i get
even this year i probably had 20 or 30
children come and ask me for pogo sticks
and is there do you go ahead sorry and
of course there's a lot of children that
want the
the uh nerf guns okay and that's fine
and uh and if somebody wants a regular
gun did you help them with that or is
that you tell them i cannot legally
bring them
uh real gum because they're not old
enough i see okay
i see and uh what's the oldest person
that's ever sat on your lap probably 102
years old no way oh yeah i've had them
all the way from
three days old
to 102 102 how long was that lying to
see i wonder huh
well
you know in the malls there's a lot of
long lines okay so i try to move along
fairly quickly
and um what did the 102 year old want
for kristen do you remember
she just wants to be able to see 103.
she just wants a little bit of time she
wants a little bit of time what's some
of the cuter answers that little
children have given you over the years
you think has it been
well i've had some
uh
come and pull on my beard and then
realize it's real and run off
sometimes they may have a set an
expletive or two on the way out oh yeah
yeah
i had one little girl
who uh she was probably
maybe six years old
and i asked her what she wanted for
christmas and she said cole
and i looked at her i said you want cole
and i looked at her mother who was
standing there beside her
i said to her why do you want coal
and she says
diamonds
she made the connection that if you
crush cold you'll get diamonds out of it
she's that long-term thinker and her
mama clapped her hand and said that's
what i'm talking about girl okay
so she think he'd drop her off a bag of
briquettes
yeah
dang man some of these women starting to
think long term you know they are that's
one way to do it um
do you remember me when i was a kid or
no oh i do
you were quite a handful in was i yeah
but you had fun you turned up pretty
good thank you i would imagine in the
north pole there can be a lot of like
things get to seclusion and even you
know in cold temperatures people suffer
from depression sometimes in isolation
you know and eventually even sometimes
alcoholism drug use do you guys see any
of that up there we don't have any
alcoholism and drug use but what we do
is we have one of them blue light things
that's supposed to help raise your mood
all the time so we have that oh dang
bring me one of those i'll tie it around
my neck that's what i need now do some
kids some kids freak out when they see
you santa some kids can't handle it a
lot of time you'll see uh you know
mothers will put a picture of their
child crying on santa's lap what's going
on there
what is it well some of them cry a lot
some of them will cry a little bit and
some of them will just have a total
meltdown
how do you handle that though like what
do you do at that moment well
here's what i do
i if they put them on my lap and they
start to cry i'll hold them as close as
i can so they won't hurt themselves
trying to get off and that type of thing
and then at the very end before i let
the child down i'll also cry too
because that makes a good picture for
for the parents yeah and then i'll put
the child down and sometimes the
photographer will take a picture of the
child
leaving
yeah with fear on their face sometimes
now there's a lot there's like uh
there's over the years you see a lot of
uh santas that
get
you know they show them like on bad
santa drinking alcohol and stuff like
that do you ever have you have you ever
had to use uppers or downers or side
splitters or whatever to really uh get
through the work week no not at all amen
brother
amen and is it ever do you see it in the
industry though
no i don't i haven't seen it uh not in
the real bearded santas that i see
is there a lot of kind of not beef on
the streets but is there like a lot of
like discrepancy between fake bearded
and real bearded sanders to me there is
well there's something not real there's
just a difference in the professional
now professionality of them now there
are people men who have
what there's called designer beards okay
these are made out of either
real human hair or sometimes yak hair
and once they're put on properly you
can't tell that it's not a real beard
really okay and there are some people
that and it's called designer beards
okay now those sanders are just as
professional as
the rest of us that have real beards
uh it is the
this is the sands that have the fake
bellies and the fake beards and the fake
wigs
that are
uh
of poor quality
that tend to be the ones that you have
problems with yeah
yeah i think people that aren't in it
for the real that aren't in it that
aren't fully in the heart got to be in
the heart if you don't have it in the
heart the children will see right
through you wow yeah yeah if you
somebody's getting all yacked out on
that yak i think that would be
uh that's interesting how nice is yak
here is it pretty nice oh yeah and it's
expensive too it's like uh
two to four thousand dollars for a good
beard in
wig set
um dang
that's very expensive that's pricey man
i don't know where you would get a yeah
i don't know if they still make yaks
anymore it's like oh yeah they are and
there
are people who service the santa
industry with suits all kinds of other
stuff that santa's need as well as
beards
and wigs if they need those
um where are some of the places you've
been stationed at over the years santa
like i know in since
in santa's line of work there's a lot of
places you get called on to serve
basically it's almost like the military
in a weird way it's almost like the um
it's like the military of the heart you
know uh especially around the holiday
times where are some places you got
called on to to survey well i've been in
orlando florida i've been in wichita
falls texas i've been in
baton rouge louisiana
i've been in novi michigan which is
north and east of detroit a little bit
i've been in modesto california wow
it's a lot actually been in nashville
yeah at cool springs galleria mall 07.08
how was that was that fun it was a lot
of fun i bet that was a big time too
that was before too much technology when
people were still really i think there
was a little bit more christmas spirit
out there sometimes one of the people
that came to see me and i did not
realize who she was at the time
and one of the elves working on the set
said do you know who that was and i said
no
that was hannah montana no way
miley cyrus wow and i did not realize it
at the time
would she ask for do you remember no i
don't i'm sorry well whatever it was it
seemed like she got it because she's
been having yes she's had everything
she's had everything here's a question
right here from a young lady
hey theo hey mall santa hello my
question is what's the nastiest thing
that has ever happened to you
as a mall santa baby barf
you know dog poop what is it what's the
nastiest thing that's ever happened yeah
do you ever is there ever accidents with
like children with a i'm sure huh
i've been fortunate over the years i've
not had too many accidents happen while
they're in my lap but
uh
from time to time a child will
especially the really small ones not the
not the older the not the two or three
year old who's
who is uh
scared they never vomit or anything at
least not that's not been my experience
sometimes the little bitty ones that i
hold yeah the one with the head a little
bit okay
uh
i've had a few children pee on me oh wow
uh especially if they get excited now
that's sometimes we're out on your chest
or where no right here on my lap
and what'll happen is uh
they'll get excited
and then they just it just cuts loose
that's all there is
i guess the other if you want to call it
a nasty thing from time to time
especially when you're towards the end
of the season
and the lines are long and people had to
wait in line a long time and their
children will end up
wetting themselves
what upsets me is when the parent
knows it but doesn't tell me they just
plop the child down because i have what
i call pee pads that i can put on my lap
to keep my suit from getting wet and
as well as to keep other children who
sit there afterwards from getting wet
safe yeah if they would just say
something
yeah i was wondering what you would do
so i guess you'd put a pad out or put
some flour out or something no what i do
i have little
red pea pads so it matches my oh
you guys think of everything santa i
have to all right what's up all santa
and theo gang gang what's up
here's a question from all santa what's
the um
the worst gift that a child's ever asked
for when you thought to yourself there's
no way i'm getting you that
all right thanks for taking the time
today
thank you merry christmas man that's
interesting yeah what is what is it
what's what's one of the gifts you're
like that's impossible or that's not
even
i always am careful about when children
are asking for
gifts
i never promise that i'll bring them
ex gifts
i'll tell them i'll see what i can do
and i always am looking
to make sure that what they're asking
for is age appropriate yeah
because sometimes
they're wanting the same thing that an
older sibling has but they're not ready
for that gift yet do kids ever ask for
are like teenagers ever asked for
anything that's like perverse kind of
like and you're kind of like you can't
have that no teenagers actually are are
mostly pretty good when they come to see
santa
the reason they're there
is mom wants that picture with santa
every year
i've had some people
that have been coming to see me 40 and
50 years wow
they've been coming
every year to get that picture so they
can give it to their mom one year i was
at uh when i was at cool springs there
was a ups guy who delivered to the mall
on the very last day of the season he
and his son who also works for ups would
come and get that picture so they could
give it to his mom
and his son's grandmom oh that's cool
yeah so there's a lot of people a lot of
there's a lot of tradition people come
through sure
to have a part of the same tradition and
stuff like that um have there ever been
a proposal in front of you
i probably had a half a dozen of them
over the years yeah and now how does
that usually go down when it happens do
they let you know in advance is it kind
of uh does the is it a man always
proposing
uh all the ones i've had have been men
proposing to women
we've done it a bunch of different ways
when i was in
novi michigan
i was in kind of the center part of the
mall
and up above on the second floor was a
caged jeweler
and this young lady was sitting on my
lap
and her soon-to-be husband was up at
cage jeweler and he came out to the
to the uh
edge there and hot looked down and
hollered to us
will you marry me
[Laughter]
and then he came on down the stairs in a
hurry and came to the set and gave her
the ring oh that's cool another thing
i've had was uh
they would come to the set ahead of time
and they would give me the ring and i
would have it in my pocket
and then they would be sitting on my lap
and
and uh
i would always ask the woman what she
wanted for christmas and then i would
ask the guy what he wanted for christmas
and a lot of times the guy would say
this woman here is the love of my life
and i'd really like to marry her but
things are really hard right now and so
i can't get her a ring
so then i'll reach in my best pocket and
i'll say well just a second i think i
may have something that'll help you out
and of course give it to him and he
opens it up and she's all a gas you know
wow that's the magic right there huh and
i'll tell you another thing that's
happened is uh birth announcements
okay
i've had several people bring
with them
to see me and they will bring the
sonogram of the ultrasound that they had
taken and get you to autograph it or
something no i would hold it up they
would be sitting here and i would hold
it up and we'd be smiling and i would
kind of point at it yeah yeah and people
think you're the dad no no no no they
don't i don't think they think that but
anyway i would look dude if santa was my
dad you know excited
if you'll be like what does your dad do
like uh he works at the bank i'm like oh
my dad santa my dad santa wow that's
pretty magical so there's really an
element too of your job where it's just
people where you there's moments where
you're really involved in the magic of
life
yes
that's awesome man
it's a lot of fun i bet that's really
awesome has there been anybody that's
come to see you that's kind of been on
their way out of the world you know
that's leaving life and they wanted to
come see santa one more time
yes uh
it's not so much
older people
but it is parents who bring their child
who has a terminal illness
and
i always have a special bell that i give
to children like that and
about eight years ago i had given one to
this little
girl
she had spina bifida and some other
problems going on
in about uh
this was early in the season and
probably about a
week or ten days later
uh
the mom comes back
and she's just bawling in tears and then
i realized who she was
and she came back to tell me that her
child had died
and she buried her child with that bell
that i had given her
yeah it's interesting uh i think people
you you know they look to santa i think
as like a symbol of like hope and
oh yeah love
you know
a symbol of magic
you know a symbol of what else uh could
be out there that we don't know from
time to time usually five or six times a
year
i will have a child come
to me and tell me santa i don't want you
to bring me anything this year
i want my friend or my cousin or my mom
or my dad to get a special christmas
is that pretty remarkable when you see
that when a kid asks yeah and here's
what i do first of all
if you think about children most
children are takers
they take stuff they want stuff given to
them oh yeah there are very very few
children that are what i call giver
children
they want to give to other people
they don't want something for themselves
so when i when that child
when i see that child and we're done
with the visit i bring the parents in or
the parent if there's only one that came
with them
and i'll say do you know what your child
your little girl your little boy asked
me for
and
they'll say no
and i said i'll then tell them the story
of what the child asked me for
in about half the time the parents will
know that they have that child's a giver
child wow about the other half of the
time the parents had no idea
but they're thrilled that
their child is that way and i said i
said and that's when i make the
the gift of the bell to the child i have
the parent and the child there and i'm
explaining to them what's
what's transpired
and i'll tell the child that every time
you ring that bell i'll be thinking
about you oh i love that yeah
you know there's something special about
just being that uh
it's almost to get like you're like a
middleman for um
yeah it's like you're like a middleman
for some of the joy that's out in the
world right it must feel pretty
interesting sometimes it is it's it's uh
it's a lot of responsibility
but it's uh
gratefully accepted responsibility amen
yeah yeah i bet this just to have to be
able to be like at work and have a few
moments like that some people don't have
moments like that in their job their
entire lives you know so to be able to
have that and then also uh
not only just like take it and be like
this is what i'm doing but take it and
just act the part of
being kind of just part of the current
right of whatever that good energy is
and i've had children as well as adults
that asked me to pray with them and i
will pray with them
right there right there on the set
before they leave amen
are there a lot of good kids out there
you think oh yeah there are a lot of
great children out there i like your
attitude yeah anything else we got for
santa sean i think that's all
man santa we know you're so busy
you know and we just thank you so much
for stopping by
um
is there any other messages you have for
the kids out there i just want you all
to be happy with everything i bring you
and uh love what the elves have made you
take really good care of because it
takes them a long time to make that
stuff
ho ho ho merry christmas
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one